[Music]
[Music]
memorial day in israel is a day
when people across the country gather
and remember those who were killed
in the military typically in conflict
[Music]
ludmila ruschkoff's son german rushkoff
was killed in march of 2002.
when someone is killed in the army a
delegation is given the very solemn and
difficult task of going to the family
and telling them what has
happened they arrived at ludmila's
apartment and she tried to block the
door in the hope of blocking the truth
she was just
beside herself with grief and at a
certain point she said we must get
german's sperm
uh
a
in israel there is a growing practice
of post-mortem sperm retrieval in which
if a man dies in the military
his family can ask the military to
retrieve sperm from his corpse and to
freeze it to create a future child
the sperm in his testicles continued to
survive
for certainly 24 hours and indeed
possibly up to 72.
a skilled doctor can remove sperm cells
from his testicle and put them on ice
and it can then sit for decades and
through in vitro fertilization create a
child
it is banned in a number of countries
but in israel which has an enormous
embrace
of pro-natal and fertility policies in
order to build a strong population it is
in fact increasingly common
people who die in car accidents of
cancer
and so forth their families have asked
to use it we're not talking about huge
numbers but in israel the focus right
now
is on
young men who die in the military
sperm extraction
is actually something that we've been
doing for as long as i remember
but in the last years it became more and
more
frequent
i'm on call 24 7 and sometimes i get a
phone call in the middle of the night
i watch tv and i see some breaking news
of some terrorist attack in tel aviv or
nearby
i tell myself okay sure enough they they
will call me
these relatives are in
deep grief they just been notified that
their loved one was killed within a few
hours they can get an approval from a
judge
for us to perform
this procedure
there is like a glimpse of hope and and
maybe a little bit of light
there is a lot of responsibility because
you are helping to create
a child who is
an orphan to begin with
post-mortem sperm retrieval
has been more common when the man is
married but really what is so striking
about the situation in israel is many
people feel i want to be a grandparent
this is an important stage of life that
i deserve and if the state has asked my
son for service and he dies in that
service it owes me
this help in becoming a grandparent
[Music]
it is now relatively common should a
young man die in the military for the
parents to be aware that they can ask
for this and then the military will pay
for the procedure as is ludmilla
rushkoff who said i have lost my only
son i want a grandchild and the court
acknowledged and agreed to that
in many ways ludmilla was a pioneer who
brought this to israel and interestingly
she's not a native-born israeli she
comes from crimea
it's
german
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
ludmilla took a long time to
decide how to proceed
it was about a dozen years after
and then it took four years of a court
battle
for them to get permission to use the
sperm and the judge that they faced
quoted from the the hebrew bible saying
pro or vu be fruitful and multiply but
complications arose in the court cases
because of the question of who is in
charge of this sperm
this is not the same thing as giving
your kidney or your eye this is creating
another human being
the supreme court made a ruling based
not on the bible but on what case law
existed a decision which said there is
no such thing as a right to
grandparenthood we cannot
grant this sperm to someone other than
the widow and essentially sent a message
to the knesset to the parliament that
said if you want this thing to move
forward we need a law
there are people creating a law which
will ask every young man when he is
inducted into the military at the age of
18
whether he has something he would like
done with his sperm should he die in
uniform
sonamite
[Music]
[Music]
b
there is an incredible incredible focus
on the family in israel and on having
babies so israel has
from the very beginning
viewed its role as a place to rebuild
the jewish nation why it comes of course
just a few years after the nazi
holocaust in which 6 million jews were
slaughtered
so even though there's a fairly heavily
religious component in israel
the fact is there's a secular drive to
have children in a way that is
incomparable in the rest of the wealthy
world
[Music]
we combine this with the
exceptional place of the military in
israeli society where essentially
everyone puts in for boys three years
for girls a little under two years of
military service
so everyone is linked to this
institution and when someone dies
serving his country
the desire to honor that person is also
very pronounced and so parents
go on to facebook or they get
interviewed on television and they say
my son
died in the service of this country and
we're looking for a woman to bear and
raise his child and what is remarkable
is that hundreds indeed thousands of
women
raise their hands and volunteer to be
that mother
be
[Music]
[Music]
has been very involved with the sv
hauser law and others because
since the supreme court said we need to
really have evidence that this young man
wanted children
he said i want to put all my energy into
creating a law instead of trying to go
through the court system
although he said i'm certain that he
very much wanted to be
a father and he said to me he has a book
of 5 000 names of women who want to be
the mother of his future grandchild
a
m
[Music]
foreign
broadly israel
very much embraces this process
but there are dissenters
there are deep worries ethical and legal
people are saying i don't understand why
would you do this on purpose you're
condemning this child to being a kind of
living monument as opposed to having a
relatively normal life life is hard
enough
so barak is very involved in lobbying
for this law
he is politically savvy and connected so
he's used those connections for this
cause but he's not alone there is a a
non-profit uh organization advocating
for this and getting everybody on board
there obviously is hesitation of the
defense ministry and others to
institutionalize something like this but
it looks like it has the wind at its
back right now
eventually
alicia
foreign
[Music]
so when you first hear about this
procedure
it's hard not to feel a little bit
freaked out
at the same time when you meet these
families and the fervor and love
that they bring to this fight you melt
because you see
that what is it that drives us in life
is love
and these people are engaged in a fight
for familial love and that's a very
powerful force
[Music]
you